South by Southwest is one of the biggest
creative meeting of minds in the country
annually it's a Film Festival it's a
music festival it's a tech festival and
now an activism festival so this year I
decided to go down with my production
team and see just for what it was that
they were advocating this was a panel
that we thought we really needed to
highlight because it was supposed to be
about countering extremism online that's
how it was billed but right away it got
to the topic of free speech in the
modern digital age let's see how they
began the discussion is very much linked
I think it's not blanket across the
European Union or the continent I
personally don't think that all types of
speech are protected right away to
anyone who's been following the
suppression of information online that's
disconcerting so when they open the
floor to questions I went up right away
to voice my concerns which actually
didn't even seem to occur to anyone else
in that room there definitely since this
conversation is really concerning
intangible variables that capability
quantified as to what's allowed on
Facebook or YouTube who defines what a
Nazi is were writing extremists as
someone who has been
accused of being that several times
officially by organizations like anti
fun care not allowed to travel to
certain countries I'm sure you're aware
of people like Tommy Robinson have been
jailed for speech since none of this can
be quantified
why don't we err on the side of freedom
I mean it's only alright Nazi who
literally probably supports this girl
more than anyone in this room and was a
Carly Fiorina voter in the primaries and
my VP is Jewish he's my other producer
who's gay who gets to define it why
should we ban any speech online now this
gentleman didn't answer my question
right away he took a few other questions
before coming back to it in order to
completely not answer so I get to answer
Mike than you if you want to come back
up and ask more questions than maybe the
chair aquestion about definitions I
think is a very difficult one because
again who's going to agree on how this
works
in different countries it goes through
different types of legislation in an
ideal situation there's a societal
discussion about what should you commit
much recommend what sort of cycling
should they do is recycle should not
happen to violence I think most people
agree should not be protected speech
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much speech is very
clearly this is what we're all talking
about speech here but some speech is
like go forth and kill all these certain
kinds of people that speech yes so
that's where the line is it comes to
definitions again you are going to have
different approaches in different places
in the UK certain types of speech are
not permitted that would be permitted in
the United States we've seen that many
times and I think that there's a genuine
discussion that can we have between
proponents of different approaches and
we should assume that our approach or
your approach or any voice which has all
of the answers now not wanting to
interrupt the panel any further and
being behind enemy lines I decided to
wait until after the session ended to
approach him and respectfully ask the
question again what is hate speech and
who defines them
like that what's the answer sir you said
if someone yields fire he is right now I
hear can you switch that off sure we're
getting freaky free speech it is a
single party consent stay that is good
like the answer okay can you just back
up for you surprise we'll be releasing
more footage from South by Southwest
here on the YouTube channel and for mug
club members a lot of credit calm slash
mug club most concerning to me and
you'll see a theme as we continue along
this series is that this is the first
generation of supposed creative artists
who are demanding less freedom who are
demanding more government infringement
into people's lives who are demanding
more suppression of speech this is just
one example but stay tuned for more and
thanks for watching if you like this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you didn't like
this video you should subscribe anyway
because then you can watch the next
video and what you can do is down vote
it and leave a comment that's really
negative you know particularly if it's
something like I don't know maybe anti
somatic even though I'm not Jewish or
something about my hair or something
about my weird nose just leave a really
negative comments that everyone else
around can act like they care